[Music]
Movie Up Pixar
my mom
today
and
so once more
Eminem
Android future
May
Lotion
There are many things that come to mind right now, but what comes
to mind right now
is the memory of going to the English Village in Paju when I was in the 5th or 6th grade of elementary school
and getting a
bed.
I went up
, it didn't stand out too much, and
it felt like it would be okay, since it wasn't too flashy, so it felt like it would be okay.
PE class But I
liked
lunch
time the most.
I was there and a
great tsunami struck,
but there is no such dream that I lived without dying while rescuing people like some kind of disaster movie,
and I gave my
body a little bit to help people,
but I don't
think there is
any.
I think it's a habit and I
accept it. Well, I'm
going to live doing things that are a bit annoying to other people, so I don't really
care
because I
'm in a lot of ways, but I'm the one
who can express myself the best and penetrate me the most.
I think it's a song
[Music]